We are taking your calls at (617) 830-4750
sort of a different Friday show today.
No audience
fins, no classic interview.
Doing a more new stories than we normally
do because I was away for a couple of days
in la doing a few different appearances, including
with Joe Rogan.
Let's go to, uh, Oh, you know what?
Alex is on the phone.
Alex, who interrupts is on the phone.
That's how we have them labeled and we haven't
heard from Alex since January.
So, uh, what, what's going on Alex?
Hey, my question is in regards to citizens
United, I know you touched on it a few times,
so there's no limit to how much you can make,
how much money you can make on political speech.
I mean, Washington Post did a Superbowl ad
that was $5 million, so there's no limit there.
Hold on a second.
So, wait, let me see if I understand there
was no limb.
I'm trying to understand no limit to how much
you can make on political speech because the
Washington Post spent $5 million on an ad.
I don't know that I understand what you mean.
Well, that obviously means they make millions
of dollars, right?
Yeah.
It's a big corporation and they make a lot
of money.
Yeah.
Okay.
I agree with that.
They make the Washington Post makes money.
So what's wrong with spending as much as you
want on political speech?
I have no idea how the two things are even
related.
Well, in regard to the citizens United, you
know what citizens United is, right?
Yes.
You know the background of it,
I mean informed me if you think there's an
element of it I don't understand.
Okay,
well they want to limit how much, um, people
can spend before an election
who wants to limit,
but the people who are against citizens United,
the people that took citizens United to court,
right.
There are people who want to level the playing
field when it comes to political spending
in order to make our system more like those
of other countries.
Yes, that's true.
There's people who think that money in politics
is not a good force.
Go on.
Okay.
Well why?
Because it has a corrupting influence.
We already have a system where the rich and
corporations have an outsized amount of influence,
not because they necessarily have better ideas,
but because they are able to pedal that influence
and use lobbyists.
And political donations and packs to get politicians
to pay.
Hold on.
I'm in the middle of of xsplit.
Do you want to hear my explanation or not,
Alex?
I'm listening.
Okay.
We already have a system where even though
everybody gets one vote, the desires and the
policies that would benefit the vast majority
of people are not taken as seriously by our
elected officials, as are the desires of large
corporations and rich people because of their
ability to use money in politics to get what
they want to be.
The priorities of our elected officials and
people who want to, even the playing field
want to even the playing field of influence
as well.
Okay, well, you know voters, they want to
know who's going to be good for the country,
so all this is is information.
If you want somebody to win, you have to show
that they're going to be good for the country.
Who has to show why can't you?
Why can't you send that information to as
many people as you want?
It would be great if everybody could send
all of that information to as many people
as they want.
The problem is rich [inaudible], rich people
and big corporations have the money to send
whatever messages they want, regardless of
whether they are accurate or not.
And poor people, middle income people, small
business owners who might have the exact same
desire to reach just as many people can't
do it merely because they don't have enough
money.
Right.
That's speech, you know, it costs money to,
to speak.
You try and reach as many people as you can.
Yeah.
You do that yourself, you know.
Right.
So what's your point?
So let me see if I understand.
You just want, you just think unlimited political
spending is fine, it sounds like.
Yes.
Okay.
All right, good.
So we disagree.
We just disagree about that.
All right.
Thanks Alex.
I appreciate the phone call.
Trade of information.
David.
I'm not afraid of people.
Okay.
Oh, um, he's not afraid of information.
Got It.
All right.
Just so people know, there's a delay on the
hangup.
So had, I actually did want to hear the rest
of what he was saying there, but you can't
undo, you can't unring the bell once I hit
the hang up button.